Speaker 1: We have another follow up, by the
way, to do Yesterday I played for you this
incredible video of Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell directly calling the Jan.
six Trump riots a violent insurrection. This is a
very different approach than what the Republican
National Committee has said. The Republican
National Committee has really danced around
actual serious, full throated indictments
of what happened on the Trump riots
at the Trump riots as an attempted coup or a
violent insurrection. They've played coy, and they
have even censured Adam Kinzinger and Liz Cheney,
two Republicans who have been willing to tell the
truth about the Trump riots. Mitch McConnell said
it was a violent insurrection. And as expected,
Donald Trump has actually lost his mind over this.
He's completely triggered. Just as a reminder,
here is what Mitch McConnell had to say
Speaker 5: censure two sitting members of
Congress and also used the words
Legitimate political discourse.
Speaker 6: You're talking about January six. Well,
let me give you my view of what happened January
the 6th and we're all. We're here, we're here. We
saw what happened. It was a violent insurrection
for the purpose of trying to prevent
the peaceful transfer of power
after a legitimately certified election.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Undeniably true.
And yet we knew that Donald Trump was not going
to like it at the time that we went. We produced
yesterday's show. We didn't have a response from
Trump. Now we do. And it is as crazy as you can
imagine Donald Trump putting out a statement
yesterday saying quote, Mitch McConnell does
not speak for the Republican Party. He kind of
does. I mean, in a way, he kind of does. But OK,
Mitch McConnell does not speak for the Republican
Party and does not represent the views of the vast
majority of its voters. That part may be true.
Many Republican voters have fallen for the Big
Lie. Trump goes on to say he Mitch did nothing
to fight for his consistent constituents and stop
the most fraudulent election in American history.
Now it's a lie that it was a fraudulent election,
and he does nothing to stop the lawless
Biden administration. The invasion of our
Capitol borders, rising capital inflation
capital you unconstitutional mandates
the persecution of political opponents, fact
finding on the incompetent Afghanistan withdrawal,
the giving away our energy independence, etc.,
which is all because of the fraudulent election.
Instead, he bails out the Capitol are radical
left and the rhinos. Now what Trump is very wrong
about here is while Mitch McConnell correctly
called the Trump riots a violent insurrection.
Mitch McConnell is actually doing a lot to get
in the way of Joe Biden. Mitch McConnell and
Republicans are still obstructing so much of what
Joe Biden wants to do. So even while Trump is mad
that as he sees it, Mitch McConnell
is not interrupting Trump enough.
Mitch McConnell is doing what he always does,
and that's obstructing Trump. Going back to
the statement, Trump going on to say if Mitch
would have fought for the election, it's like,
Dude, you lost. What can you do? If Mitch would
have fought for the election, like the Democrats
would have if in the same position, we would not
be discussing any of the above today. And our
Capital C country would be all caps strung and
all caps proud instead of weak and embarrassed.
Exactly what we expected from Donald Trump. And we
can only hope. Listen, we Joe Biden's approval is
not looking good. The House of Representatives
for Democrats now looking great for November,
the Senate for Democrats is not
it. None of it is looking good.
If we can seize on anything to try to try to get
mitigated disastrous results in November, it is
Republicans fighting like this and hopefully some
of them getting so disgusted with this Republican
civil war and infighting that they
decide to stay home. That's the hope.
And of course, we're going to have to
wait and see whether that actually happens